[Music]
my name is Sarah Robinson I'm a
developer advocate on the Google cloud
platform team you can find me on twitter
at s robb tweets and i'm gonna be joined
later in the presentation by nick hasty
from our customer giffy and my teammate
Zach Akhil another developer advocate so
let's get started by talking about what
is machine learning so at a high level
machine learning involves teaching
computers to recognize patterns in the
same way that our brains do so as humans
it's really easy for us to distinguish
between a cat and a dog but it's much
more difficult to teach a computer to be
able to do the same thing but how do we
actually get from input to prediction
this is gonna depend on the type of
problem you're solving I like to think
of it along a spectrum so on the left
hand side let's say you're solving a
generic task something that someone has
already solved before on the opposite
side of the spectrum
maybe you're solving something very
custom that's specific to your data set
let's think of us more specifically in
terms of image classification so for
example let's say we have this image of
a cat so the input to our model is the
pixels in the image and we want our
model to output the label that there's a
cat in this image so many of you know
this is a pretty common machine learning
task there's lots of pre trained models
out there that exists that have been
trained to identify a broad range of
categories and images and so you don't
need to start from scratch you can
utilize an existing model but let's say
we have the same image and we want this
cat's name is Chloe and we want our
model to be able to identify Chloe apart
from the other cats in our image library
and maybe we even want our model to be
able to draw a bounding box around her
in the image so this is gonna require us
to provide our own training data so that
our model is able to differentiate
between the different cats in our image
library let's think of this one other
way in terms of natural language
processing so let's take for example
this text from one of my tweets let's
say I want to extract the parts of
speech from the text I want I want my
model to be able to tell me what words
are verbs nouns and pronouns this is a
pretty common natural language
processing task so again I don't need to
start from scratch I can utilize an
existing pre trained model to help me
with that
but let's say I've got the same input
and I want my model to know that this is
a tweet about programming and more
specifically it's a tweet about Google
cloud so for that to work I'm gonna need
to give my model hundreds or thousands
of tweets about each of these topics so
that it's going to be able to generalize
and extract those topics from new tweets
that it hasn't seen before so in this
talk I want to show you how easy it is
to add machine learning to your
application using many tools we have
available on Google cloud platform so
starting on the left hand side products
that are targeted more towards
application developers we have a set of
machine learning api's so these api's
give you access to pre trained models
you just need to write one REST API
request and you can access all these pre
trained models that we've already
trained for you you don't need to
provide any of your training data so it
requires no machine learning expertise
to get started on the other side of the
spectrum we have products that are
targeted more towards data scientists
and machine learning practitioners
people that have a little bit more ml
experience so for this we have cloud
machine learning engine which is our
managed platform for training and
serving your own custom machine learning
models so until recently you'll notice
there was kind of a gap in the middle
this is why I'm super excited about Auto
ml which you may have heard about in the
keynote
so Auto ml is a tool that lets you train
your own custom machine learning models
without writing model code so it get
lets you get a little bit more custom
than you would with the api's for
example so you provide your own training
data currently available for images text
and translation so now that you know the
three different product areas we're
going to be covering let's dive right in
with machine learning as an API so as I
mentioned we have five pre-trained api's
that give you access to pre trained
machine learning models to accomplish to
accomplish common ML tasks like
analyzing images analysing scenes in a
video converting audio to text analyzing
that text a little further and then
finally translating that text into over
a hundred different languages I'm going
to focus on just two of the api's vision
and natural language to give you a taste
of what the api's can provide so
starting with vision these are all the
features of our cloud vision API so at
its core the vision API will answer the
question
what is this a picture of that's label
detection so for this image in my return
elephant animal etc web detection will
go a step further and it will look
across the web for similar or identical
images I mean based on the content of
those pages it'll return tags back for
you on what what's in your picture OCR
stands for optical character recognition
so this can extract text from images it
can tell you where that text is and it
can even understand the language of that
text skipping ahead to explicit content
detection this will tell you is my image
appropriate or not
this applies to pretty much any site
that has user-generated content so
instead of having someone manually
screen each image you just make one API
call that'll tell you is this image
appropriate or not so this is what a
vision API request looks like you'll
notice here we're passing in the URL of
an image in Google Cloud storage you can
also pass in your base 64 encoded image
directly in your API requests and then
in the features block we just tell the
API what types of detection we want to
run so it's just a REST API you can call
it in any language I've chosen to
include a Python example here um so we
have many client libraries to help you
access these api's in your favorite
languages so here we're using the google
cloud vision module for python we're
creating an image annotator client and
then we're running label detection and
analyzing those responses so I never
like to get too far into a talk without
a demo so let's go to the demo so to
show you what's possible with the vision
API this is the vision API product page
and you can try out all of our api's
directly in the browser by uploading
your own images so here what I can do is
I can upload an image I'm gonna choose
this selfie that I took when I was
seeing Hamilton a couple months ago and
we can see everything we get back from
the vision API so face detection is able
to tell where my face is in the image
it's also able to detect emotion so it
says joy is very likely I was super
excited to be seeing Hamilton so that
it's accurate it also identifies where
different features are in my face if we
skip ahead to web detection based on
other pictures of the same theatre it's
able to
by the exact leader where I'm standing
even though the lighting in the picture
isn't great my favorite part about this
is what's returned from our text
detection endpoint so when I first
uploaded this image we ran it through
the vision API I didn't even see any
text in the image but you'll notice that
the word playbill is here on my program
book and the API is able to identify
that for us and then skipping ahead here
we can look at the full JSON response
right in the browser so I encourage you
all to try this out with your own images
see if the vision API is right for you
before you start writing any code so
that's the vision API we can go back to
the slides and I'll include a link to
that demo at the end so that was the
vision API
moving right along into cloud natural
language so the natural language API
provides four different features first
it lets you extract entities from text
and then it lets you detect sentiment so
it can tell you is this text positive or
negative if you want to get a little bit
more into the linguistic details of your
text you can use the analyze syntax
endpoint and then finally the newest
feature of this is the content
classification so you can classify your
text into over 700 different categories
this is an example of calling the
natural language API in nodejs again
it's just a REST API so you can use it
in any language you'd like so here we're
calling the analyzed sentiment endpoint
and then we're analyzing the sentiment
of our text so let's go into a demo of
the natural language API again I'm going
to show the product page here so right
in the browser for the on the NLL api
product page i can enter text directly
in here so i'm going to enter some new
text so this is a sentence from an
article about the world cup published
just a couple weeks ago and we will see
what the NL API is able to identify so
we can see it extracts all of these
entities from our text so if the entity
returns a Wikipedia page it will link to
that page in the response so this is one
of the players it links to the Wikipedia
page about him this links to the
Wikipedia page about the French national
football team which is why it's
categorized as an organization type and
then we also get this sentiment for each
entity broken down by entity so
score is a value ranging from negative
one to one telling us if this entity is
overall positive or negative so that's
what we get through entity analysis
sentiment will give us the overall
aggregate sentiment of the entire
document along with the sentiment for
each sentence from the syntax response
we get some additional linguistic
details about the text which you can see
here parts of speech the role of each
word in the sentence and then finally
the content classification endpoint is
able to identify that this is an article
about soccer with eighty percent
confidence it's pretty cool considering
the words soccer football World Cup are
not actually explicitly mentioned in the
text and you can also look in the
documentation to see a full list of the
content categories that are available
from this method so that was the natural
language API demo we can go back to
slides next I want to highlight one of
our customers that's using both the
vision and natural language API is in
production and for that I want to
welcome to the stage Nick hasty who's
the director of R&D at giffy welcome
Nick thanks Sarah
so I hi my name is Nick hasty I'm
director of research and development for
giphy gifties about five year old
start-up we have about 700 employees 75
in New York about 25 in LA so today I'm
going to talk to you about how giffy
used the Google cloud vision API s and
the Google cloud natural language API s
to get better metadata about our gifts
and to also increase our search
experience so yeah so the problems that
we were facing about two years ago we
were accumulating so many images so many
gifts that the ways in which we
annotated those gifts just weren't
cutting it anymore we had an editorial
team you know they would add tags and
labels to gifts but we were working in
tins and millions of gifts and we were
getting thousands more every day it's
just not the best you
of our resources internally to have
people slaving away all day you know
adding tags at this point in time there
was a good amount of availability of
machine learning resources for object
detection in in images we evaluated a
lot of different options on including
you know open source ones but those have
their own problems like you got to
deploy and you got to do all these other
things maintain services and these kinds
of things we found that the Google Cloud
API was the best thing for us overall
again we were trying to do is pretty
simple we just wanted we had a bunch of
images we just wanted to figure out what
was inside those images for gif feed
knowing if a cat is in the is an image
there's actually a big business deal for
us so we wanted to pull those things out
in a minute
so yeah it any startup you know you
don't to reinvent the wheel and you want
to minimize risk so for us to not have
to train our own custom thing and to
just be able to hit an API with an HTTP
request and get a really good quality
metadata about an image huge makes a job
that would historically or you know
anytime be like a whole team to a single
person so let me show you some of the
results we get for this so these are a
be test results on the left hand side
you can see improvements in CTR for
soldiers for our search results pages
across our owned and operated so the
bottom line the dark blue line is the
control group and the top line is the
light blue is our experiment group the
experiment group we added on Google web
entities into our search algorithm as a
signal Google web entities for us were
really awesome because not only do they
provide generic labels since they
understand the context in which a gif is
found on the internet there's a lot of
time like proper names in there so you
might you know find celebrities TV shows
those kinds of things which is our bread
and butter so yeah when we did this a B
test you could see an eighty six point
eight six percent relative increase in
CTR which is a really good metric for us
and for any kind of CTR evaluation and
then also the other byproduct of this
was we were turning a less
empty searches so on the right side
those are nonzero results so we were
turning so as you can see we had a
higher percentage of searches that were
not empty so a person would search for
something they wouldn't get anything
back reason being we had more metadata
about our gifts which increased our
overall overall relevance the other
thing too is like a lot of our long tail
searches we noticed those got really
much better because a lot of the stuff
it was in kind of metadata limbo you
know we didn't really have good metadata
around it
now that we did those things started
coming up bubbling up in the algorithm
so as we scroll down our pages when our
search results we were just seeing
better stuff all around these numbers
may seem kind of smaller in terms of a
you know like under 1% but if he serves
about 5 billion gifts a day to 300 daily
active users so any increase in this
amount is like substantial ok here's
another thing we did hopefully you can
see this we needed to come up with
better ways to title our gifts we use
the titles anytime we display gifts on
the website and their mobile apps and
these other things so the old way we did
this before
we use Google natural language
processing API it wasn't we would just
get the most popular tag on a gift and
then we would say most popular tagged
gift not always wrong but like you know
not really good so you can see in the
upper left there's a chipmunk on the bed
that was just bed gif elephant jumping
robe that was just an animal gift and a
guy professing his love to a woman at
the door was just a love gift so what we
wanted you to increase these titles we
came up with a bunch of semantic
structures like noun verb adjective noun
verb that we knew that would be the best
titles for us then we took all our tags
our subsets of our tags rather we sent
into the Google natural language
processing api's we figured out their
parts of speech
the other cool thing is the Google
natural language API is returned
Wikipedia articles and they return
knowledge graph references so we were
able to cross-reference those resources
to figure out when we had a tag that was
like a proper noun or those kinds of
things
so then we got that data and we apply
the other structures started producing
titles for these images you can see
bottom left yawn stretch gif elephant
jump rope gif valentine's day hello gif
way better we were super stoked with all
that that's it for us real quick again
thanks my name is Nick hasty you can
give me Nick a giffy comm and below that
is a billy URL that leads to a blog post
article on the Google cloud machine
learning blog where I go into more
detail about all this thank you thanks
Nick
awesome to see about customers using
these api's in production so a lot of
times when I present on our API is the
first question I always get is what if I
want to train these api's on my own
custom data and for that I'm super
excited about our newest product in
cloud machine learning cloud Auto ml
which lets you train your own custom
machine learning models for vision
natural language and translation without
requiring you to write any of the model
code so this is a diagram of how it
works you upload your training data
could be images for auto ml vision
documents text sentences for auto ml
natural language and then sentence
translation pairs for using auto ml
translate auto ml provides a UI for
uploading your training data making sure
your data is labeled correctly you just
click a button to train it and then you
get access to a custom REST API to make
predictions on that data
an Auto ml handles scaling it for you so
if your model becomes a smash hit you
get hundreds of thousands of requests
Auto ml will scale up and then it'll
also scale all the way back down to zero
so you only pay for what you use so
let's get started right with Auto ml
vision I mean to show you autumn olive
vision we're gonna dive right into a
demo and for this demo let's pretend
that I am a meteorologist and I want to
predict weather trends and flight plans
from images of clouds so this begs the
question can we use the cloud to analyze
clouds the answer is yes so as I was
prepping this demo I learned that
there's many different types of clouds
and they all indicate different weather
patterns so my first thought was let's
try this out with the vision API
so for us it's easy to see that these
are obviously two different types of
clouds but for the vision API was
trained on a broad range of different
categories of images we wouldn't really
expect it to know the scientific names
for these types of clouds you can see
that for both of them it returns pretty
much the same labeled sky clouds blue
etc so the answer was build a custom
model in auto ml vision and let's jump
over to the demo to take a look at that
so this is the auto ml vision UI um it
takes me through every step of building
training my model so here what we have
is the Images tab it shows me all the
images that I'm using to train my model
I can either create a CSV with the URLs
of my images in Google Cloud storage and
in the second column I would have the
Associated label or I can upload my
images directly in the UI right here so
you can see in this model our model is
going to recognize five different types
of clouds as we see here and this is the
number of photos that I have for each
one so once I've got all my data in Auto
ml vision the next step is to jump over
here to the train tab so this is where I
can train my model I can look at some
metrics so when I click train I can
choose how long I want to train it for
right there and once my model is done
training I'll get an email and then it's
time to look at some metrics to see how
my model performed and what I want to
highlight here is the confusion matrix
so it's called a confusion matrix it's
actually not that confusing what we want
to see here is a strong diagonal from
the top left so this tells us the
percentage of images in our test set
that our model is able to classify
correctly so when we uploaded all of our
images to auto ml vision it
automatically split our images for us
into training and testing so when we're
building any sort of machine learning
model we want to take the majority of
our data and use it to train the model
but then when we test the model to see
how it performed we want to use data
that it's never seen before
so this is evaluating on the test data
so we can see that it identified 92% of
my cumulus clouds correctly did pretty
good for most of them but for this one
it looked like there were some issues so
for altostratus that only got 58% of
those correct turns out it mislabeled a
lot of a lot
them as cirrus clouds and I can click
here to see where my model got confused
so these were images it predicted
correctly these are images that we're
confusing so this is where I can see
maybe these images were labeled
incorrectly maybe they're confusing
images that I should just delete for my
data set this UI helps you go in and see
where you need to improve your training
data so that's the evaluate tab and the
most fun part of this process is
generating predictions once you've got a
train model there's a couple ways to do
this
I'm gonna show you how to do it in the
UI so for this we're gonna upload images
of two different types of clouds and
we're gonna see what our model predicts
and there we go so this is a
cumulonimbus cloud 96% confident that it
predicted that one correctly this is a
mean type of cloud you probably wouldn't
want to see it if you were on a plane
this one is a cirrus cloud it got 96
percent confidence so you can try out
your predictions in the UI it's a great
way to see higher model works right
after it's been trained but chances are
you probably want to build an
application that's going to make
prediction request to your train model
so you get access to this custom API
endpoint only you have access to this or
anyone that you share your project with
and let's say I decide to add a bunch
more images to improve the accuracy my
model I train a new version all I need
to do or all the application developer
needs to do is change this model ID in
the API request so that is Auto ml
vision we can go back to the slides so
we announced Auto ml vision earlier this
year and some companies that have been
participating in alpha versus Disney
Disney built a model to identify
specific Disney characters product
categories and colors that were specific
to them and they use that to improve the
accuracy of their search results Urban
Outfitters is a clothing company they
built a similar model to identify
characteristics in clothing so types of
patterns and clothing types of neckline
styles things like that they're using it
to automatically tag products and
improve their recommendations and search
results so those are some examples of
companies using auto ml vision in
production
but vision is just one domain of machine
learning and so what about other types
of data like text that's where Auto ml
natural language comes into play so I
wanted to start out by talking about a
couple of potential use cases of Auto ml
natural language why you might want a
custom text classifier so these are just
a couple examples that I thought of the
first was let's say you you've got some
data like a stack overflow question and
you want your model to automatically tag
that question with an Associated
programming language or maybe you want
to build a model that takes a headline
news headline is able to predict where
that headline came from I actually built
a model to do this on auto ml natural
language and the results were pretty
impressive one other example is let's
say that you want to you've got doctors
notes about a patient and maybe you want
to predict the possible conditions that
would be associated with those symptoms
just show you how this works I'm gonna
use a demo you may have seen in the
keynote with a data set from
DonorsChoose so I found this data set on
Kaggle goggle is a data science platform
that's part of Google if you haven't
heard of it I definitely recommend
checking it out they've got a lot of
great data sets on there so this data
set includes data from DonorsChoose and
what they do is they match teachers with
donors so teachers that are looking for
resources for their classroom will
create need requests they have
volunteers manually categorizing those
requests and then they use those
categories to route the requests to
relevant donors who are interested in
donating to the project so they posted
this data set to Kaggle to see if the
community of data scientists and machine
learning experts could build them an
automated solution so I thought I would
try it out with Auto ml natural language
so let's go to the demo so as you'll see
the UI for auto ml natural language
looks very similar to the UI for auto ml
vision so here we have all of the text
inputs to our model and their associated
categories and these are all the
possible categories in our data set so
we can see all the categories here and
the Train tab looks the same as Auto ml
vision we can take a look at the
confusion matrix to evaluate
the accuracy of how our model perform
you can see it's it pretty well we got
again a strong diagonal down the
top-left indicating that it categorized
a lot of the most of the text items from
our test set correctly so we want to do
next is run a prediction on some new
text that hasn't been categorized yet so
we'll head over here to predict tab and
I'm gonna take the following need
request me zoom in so you can all see
that it says my students need aquarium
lighting for our environmental clownfish
aquaculture project so this should be
classified as lab equipment and let's
see if our model is able to identify it
so there we go we can see our model
identify this as lab equipment with 98%
confidence which is pretty cool
considering this is it's not totally
obvious from the text itself that this
is the category that should be assigned
so again similar to auto ml vision we
get a custom REST API that we can use to
make predictions on our trained natural
language model so we can go back to the
slides you go back to slides there we go
so next I'm moving right along to auto
ml translate before I dive into auto ml
translate I want to talk about why
domain-specific translation is important
because often times using our cloud
translation API works great for many use
cases but there are certain situations
where you do need domain-specific
translation maybe you have a lot of
Industry specific jargon that you need
to translate so I'm going to use this
error message as an example so the
message says device driver software was
not successfully installed so let's say
I wanted to summarize this focusing here
on the word driver let's say I summarize
this to say the driver is not working
and now I want to translate that so
taken out of context of the error
message this actually might apply to a
number of things so the sentence is the
driver is not working
it could be referring to a broken golf
club my driver club is broken it could
also be referring to maybe a taxi driver
is on strike they're not working the
driver is not working or it could apply
to the software use case that we saw in
the previous slide so
this is an example of why you might need
a domain-specific translation model to
show you a demo I'm gonna use a data set
provided by one of our customers their
name is we localized we localize is one
of the largest localization providers in
the US and they help their customers
which span many different industries
localize their content for global
audiences and so we're gonna highlight
datasets provided by two of their
customers that they have experimented
with Auto ml translate for so those are
open table and blackboard so we
localized has a lot of localization
expertise because when you build an auto
ml translate model you need to provide
it with thousands of sentence pairs
translating from a source to a target
language so they have a team of experts
that helps gather about training data
and analyze the quality of the resulting
model so it open table did they've been
experimenting with auto ml translate
during the alpha they built a model that
translates from English to German to
translate restaurant reviews
descriptions and UI elements on the site
for those of you that aren't familiar
with blackboard it's an e-learning
platform it helps teachers post homework
and their courses let students engage in
discussion and look up their grades
things like that so they built a model
to translate from English to Spanish to
translate user guides and UI elements on
their site so notice that both of these
examples translate from English into a
non English language to show you a demo
I've actually reversed the sentence
pairs so that they translate into
English so you can see the benefits you
get from using the custom model the
accuracy of the reverse sentence pairs
is going to be pretty similar to the
original models that they built so if we
could go to the demo I'm going to show
you a demo for both open table and
blackboard they have different data sets
obviously so this is what the training
data looks like in auto ml translate so
here we have the German to English
sentence pairs this is the open table
example so they're translating UI
elements restaurant reviews and
descriptions on their site so we go over
here to the train tab you'll see what's
called a blue score and this is a score
that's used by neural machine
translation experts to evaluate the
accuracy of a train model
so what you
see here is you want to see a higher
blue score than the base model this is
what the translation API would provide
on the same data so here we got a
20-point improvement and what we want to
do here is generate a prediction on some
new text so I'm going to enter a
restaurant review in German and what
we'll see up here is what we get from
our custom model and then we can compare
that to what we get this is the same
exact response we get if we use Google
Translate on the same sentence so let's
take a look so the first sentence
service was nice and friendly this is
actually the same so you don't always
need a custom translation model but
there are certain use cases where it
leads to a lot of improvements in
accuracy so here we see this was
translated two drinks were upscale which
is a much better translation than the
word lifted and then right here it says
we highly recommend which again is a
better translation then we can only
recommend so we get these small
improvements which do lead to a lot of
accuracy improvements in the end so
that's the open table example looking at
a different domain let's take a look at
the blackboard model so here I'm going
to enter some text in Spanish and we'll
translate it and we'll compare the
results here so here we notice right off
the bat we get a better translation here
of this word so graters is obviously a
term that's used across blackboards
application the baseline model would
translate this to qualifiers which
doesn't really make sense in this use
case retention Center is a proper noun
in their platform which is translated
more accurately by the custom model and
then here we have swiping versus
scrolling submission versus shipment so
submission is what they want to call
submitting something in their platform
and then finally submission listing
which is a better translation than ship
list page so you can see for any
domain-specific translation use case you
do get a lot of quality improvements by
building a custom model using your own
training data for that so we can go back
to the slides and then moving into the
last part of the talk what if you have a
custom task that requires more control
over your model type and its inputs so
some examples of this are let's
you've already built your own model
you've built a model and tensorflow or
scikit-learn and you want to train that
model so maybe you want to train it on
Google cloud platform or maybe you want
to scale the way to serve that model to
handle lots and lots of prediction
requests
another example is let's say you want to
build a regression model so that's a
model that will output numerical values
so maybe you have a text input and you
want your model to assign some sort of
rating to that text or maybe you have a
model that has multiple inputs so maybe
it takes images and text as input and
then outputs some sort of prediction
based on that so these are all use cases
where you want more more control over
your model and for that we have cloud
machine learning engine which is
Google's managed platform for building
training and serving custom models using
your own data so it's our fully managed
platform for machine learning it
supports a couple of different
frameworks so it supports tensorflow
Karos and then most recently
scikit-learn and XG boost models for
serving so ml engine is a way for you to
train your models so you can take
advantage of using GPUs or TP use which
stands for tensor processing units which
will help you accelerate your machine
learning workload so you can use it for
training your models you can also use it
for serving your models so once you've
got a train model you can serve it on
cloud ml engine and then you get access
to an easy-to-use API to make
predictions on your train model one of
the great things about ml engine is that
there's no lock-in
so let's say that I want to train my
model on my own infrastructure but then
I want a way to serve it I can upload it
to ml engine for serving or vice versa I
could train it on ml engine and then
serve it somewhere else some companies
that are using machine learning engine
in production Rolls Royce has a
tensorflow model that they're using for
the company's marine division and there
they have an object detection model
which means that it returns the location
of objects in an image similar to the
cat example that I showed earlier in the
presentation they're using that to
identify and track the objects that a
vessel can encounter at sea another
example is Okada Okada is the UK's
largest grocery delivery service as you
can imagine they get tons and tons of
customer support emails on a daily basis
so they built a custom model to optimize
how they handle those requests so some
requests don't require any response at
all
some requests are very urgent so they're
able to route requests appropriately
using that custom model and to show you
a demo of ML engine I'm gonna bring up
my teammate Zach Akhil to the stage
welcome Zach Thank You Sara if we could
switch back to the slides
awesome
so I'm Zach Akhil I'm one of the
developer advocates for Google cloud
platform and I'm really excited to show
off how we can use ml engine to deploy a
custom model that work that we've built
and then how we can also integrate that
into an actual app so let's just jump
right in and look at the problem that
our app is gonna solve so this is
following given a movie description can
we predict the genre so this is an
example of a natural language problem
but as Sarah was saying we could have
easily have done an image based problem
or a numeric based problem we've just
chosen this one cause it's a bit of fun
but it'll be a bit special so let's look
at an example so here's the description
I believe it's one of the oceans films
it's got crime in it it's got action so
for our model instead of predicting just
a single genre we're actually going to
build it so that it predicts multiple
genres so this is an example of a
multi-label classification problem and
m/l engine will handle this like I said
before because it doesn't really mind
what kind of problem we're trying to
solve it will just take the models that
we built so we've actually went away
when we've built a couple of models to
solve this problem and if you want to
have a go at solving the kind of movie
related problem we've actually used this
data set from Kaggle it's a really
really good one Scott like over 40,000
movies and we had we were picking genres
and we've got loads of other features
that we didn't even use so really
recommend using that data set for the
actual app structure that we built we
aim to build an app that's as simple as
possible but one that's also completely
scalable so we built a front-end that's
just static HTML you'll see in a little
bit
a really simple text box with a button
that you just click and we've actually
just thrown that up onto the cloud
storage so cloud storage has a really
cool feature where you can just throw up
an HTML file click a button to make a
public link and it will create a public
URL that anyone can just go to and it
will render its web page so we've just
used that to host our front-end and
obviously the back end is going to be
cloud email engine that's gonna be the
heavy lifting of actually hosting or
deployed models and more specifically
the models that we've built have been a
combination of scikit-learn and
tensorflow
so you've probably already a bit
familiar with tensorflow it's Google's
deep deep learning framework but it's
anyone in the room familiar with
scikit-learn got any scikit-learn ok go
like a handful so scikit-learn is
actually a really comprehensive machine
learning library but it kind of
specializes in the parts of machine
learning that aren't deep learning so it
has a lot of algorithms for clustering
for decision trees and we're just gonna
show you how you can combine a couple of
models and why that can be advantageous
when you're trying to build machine
learning algorithms so we've got our
back-end and we've got our front-end how
we get predictions from our front end to
our back end we can send requests
directly from JavaScript front ends to
the ml engine the one restriction in
that is that all requests have to be
authenticated so we would have to build
into our front-end our way for a user to
log in with your Google credentials and
approve them to our own model so that is
actually a really good solution if you
want to restrict the users of your model
to be specific so from a certain user
group but for our one we want to be as
simple as possible so we want users to
be able to just go in and without having
to log in get predictions so that's
where we have a cloud function so we've
built a really simple cloud function all
it does is it takes whatever prediction
we're going to make so it's going to
take the description of the movie and
it's going to just slap on project
credentials and set it off to Cloud ml
engine so it's not changing any data and
a way you can think about this is it's
providing an authentication sugar
glazing on a prediction request donut so
it's not actually changing any data it's
just take
the requests were gonna make putting on
credentials and cop functions actually
come with default credentials for your
project so they're really useful for
doing this sort of thing
so let's actually stop talking about it
and just show it so we could switch over
to the demo so here is the cloud cloud
ml engine dashboard so we can see our
model here and we can actually look at
our app which is here so as I said it
was very simple app so it's just got a
movie description and a button so let's
throw in a movie description here so
we've got got this one this is one of
the Star Wars films does anyone have any
predictions for what genre it's gonna be
just shout out okay we got cypher action
okay let's see so it's gonna send a
request off to our cloud function that's
going to go off to ml Engine and it's
gonna come back with the genres so you
can see here it's predicted action
science fiction thriller the Star Wars a
thriller maybe I don't know so we're
making predictions that's the front end
let's let's look back at the at the back
end so we can go back to Cloud ml engine
so you can see we've got our model it
shows the default version so keep note
of that because we'll come back to that
later so diva version is version 1 we
can look at our model and see that we
actually have two versions of our model
we have version 1 and version 2 so when
I talking about how we built a model
with scikit-learn and a model of
tensorflow
version 1 is our scikit-learn model and
version 2 is our tensorflow model so we
can go back to our app and we can get a
prediction from our tentative remodel so
I just built in a little you are here
and boom
so that's getting predictions from a
cycler mall alongside gain predictions
from a tensorflow model and you can see
here we've got some numbers so the
tensorflow model rather than it
returning just the flags of which genre
it is it actually also returns
probabilities so we've just displayed
those as well and when we're making
requests although I've showed it was
here with us with some radio buttons all
I would do is I would specify the model
name so in this case we have a model
named movies and get prediction and
that's going to go off to our default
model so that's where the scikit-learn
mall so that's why we've got the the
same tags as our scikit-learn model
because version 1 was our default model
so if we want to be more specific we
could say get from versions
v1 and that's also going to go from our
scikit-learn model and then version 2 is
our tensorflow model so it goes to show
you how easy it is to just switch
between versions of a model when you're
making predictions on the application
side so that's version one that's
version two let's look at version three
and oops
we don't have version three so let's
actually go create version three so over
in our in our dashboard here we can go
into the cloud shell it's going to boot
up a little mini instance for us to
interact with the cloud and when it's up
we'll be able to see we'll be able to
use the Google Cloud API to build all
our models so here's here's the here's
the dashboard here's the visual shell we
can use g-cloud and it's just ml engine
and for example we can just list the
models that we have
hopefully I've spelled everything and it
should show one model call movies make
sense now let's create a new version of
that model so if we go over to our cloud
storage I've actually created a really
simple decision tree model in SK learn
and it's just sitting here in our cloud
storage so I'll run the command I've
cheated a bit here so I've copy and
paste I've made it before but I'll talk
through what it does so I'll run it and
what we're doing we're calling ml engine
we're saying okay you're going to create
a new version we're going to call it
version tree so our previous versions
were called version 1 version 2 we could
have called a version 3 but might as
well mess with the application engineers
that are going to build this and make
inconsistent naming conventions so we've
called it tree we've said ok it's going
to be a new version for our model called
movies the framework is gonna be
scikit-learn make sense
the runtime version is 1.5 and that is
the runtime version of ml engine that
we're going to use and the reason why
we've chosen 1.5 is because that's the
one that supports Python 3 models that
we've built
so our scikit-learn model when we were
building it we were building at using
Python and it was in a version of place
in three and so we tell it okay use
runtime version 1.5 because that
supports version 3 and then we specified
use Python 3 and then we've just told it
where
the models actually sorts we stored it
in that bucket that I showed you before
in fact you can see it here and it's
uploading now so what's really exciting
about why why you can upload a model
with just one command goes back to the
sort of best practice with machine
learning at the moment and that is this
kind of iterative leap frogging idea
when but you're building models so the
idea is that you build a really really
simple model to begin with even if it's
underperforming and then stop put that
to the side
and then build a second model to try to
beat that model and you sort of leapfrog
with your models so this this is great
it's a great idea except before you just
build them all and put off to the side
but now because deploying is just one
command you're able to build a model and
deploy the model and what's really is
cool about this is that for application
developers they can immediately start
building the application with the first
model and then whenever you upload more
complicated more advanced models they
don't need to change their application
so this is actually exactly how we built
this demo so I am more comfortable
scikit-learn so I started building a
slightly learned model and then I threw
up on the ml engine and whilst I was
doing that Sarah was actually building a
tensor flow model and so when I threw it
up an ml engine my cycle learned model I
went off my built the fronton that you
saw and after the front-end was done and
Sarah finished the tensor form all she
just threw it up on the ml engine and I
didn't need to change my front-end at
all I was able to immediately just get
predictions from it I didn't need to
worry about installing dependencies and
if you've tried to embed machine
learning algorithms directly into
application you know how much of a pain
is can be so that's really exciting
about ml engine okay so our models
upload it we'll go back to our app we
can see okay we're still getting
predictions from version 1 setting off
to cloud ml engine and it's going to
come back cool version 2 awesome let's
go back here let's try version 3 it's
going to fail because we didn't call it
version 3 we call it version tree
and then and you see it's it's a really
simple decision tree so it doesn't
perform quite as well but just to wrap
up with this let's let's create our own
movie so I'll say let's say the tale of
a rogue engineer trying to deploy their
model any guesses for the genre okay
there's a few there
let's see scikit-learn model that gets
comedy I guess I guess it's a funny one
I see tensorflow actually science
fiction that's pretty good okay let's
try to influence this so imagine we're a
production company we what we actually
want to make a romance so how would we
call it we would say all that blah blah
blah he falls in love who see if any of
our models pick up on it okay that one
doesn't it's like it learn hey we get we
don't have a romance okay so we could
switch back to the slides I hope that
showing you some of the power that ml
engine can bring when you're developing
your custom machine learning models and
especially how it can sort of bring
together your data scientist machine
engineers with your application
engineers in a nice harmony with that I
will hand you back over to Sarah and
enjoy the rest of the conference
[Applause]
thank sac was an awesome demo back some
slides so we covered a ton of things in
this presentation so I just wanted to
give you a quick summary to wrap up so
if you remember only three things from
the presentation one use a pre-trained
api to accomplish common machine
learning tasks like image analysis
natural language processing or
translation you don't need any of your
own training data to do that you can get
started right away
just one REST API request number two if
you want to customize these api's to
your own specific training data you can
use auto ml currently available for
images text and translation and then
finally as Zach just showed us for
custom tasks you can build a model train
it on your own data and train and serve
it on cloud machine learning engine so
that's all we've got here's some
resources if you want to learn more I'll
let folks take a photo of that slide for
a moment and thank you thanks everyone
for coming
[Applause]
[Music]